it was brought to my attention that some
of you attended what can only be
described as a party last night
i've reassured the head that the only
line breaking
that will be allowed going forwards will
be by the first 15 rugby team is that
clear
good morning everyone all right i'm not
really going to do i'm not actually
rowan atkinson it's fine it's uh yeah
everyone alright
i could do a roll call or any of the
line breakers have any of them made it
penny
henny
bueller
yeah
well morning i'm james
um so i'm gonna start off with a little
anecdote
uh because
my favorite author is a british science
fiction author called terry pratchett
now hands up who've come across terry
pratchett fancy author excellence
so terry pratchett was renowned for
turning up a convention he's quite a
self-deprecating guy
and you turn up in
conventions where in a t-shirt he had
made and that t-shirt had a number of
things on it said i think it said
tolkien's dead
jk rowling said no
philip pullman couldn't make it
hi
i'm terry pratchett
and ever since the uh the microservices
thing kicked off
uh a few years ago
i've been doing some conferences and
things i thought i'd have my own mate so
i've got my own t-shirt as an homage to
terry pratchett and what this says is
turing's dead
martin fowler said no
sam newman couldn't make it
hi i'm james lewis so you've got me this
morning i think
i think it's right i think it was the
right booking we'll we'll find out i
guess
a little while ago
a couple of months ago now still during
you know in the before times before we
were back face to face
i had an email
which i was really pleased about from um
from jacob
this is this email
it said
hi james how are you
it's like a brilliant ndc are back in
touch i get to kind of come and hang out
with everyone again it'll be excellent
i'll get to talk about technology i'll
get to understand what people are doing
especially the dot-net world i get to
see a lot of people writing a lot of
code probably a lot of goats sacrificed
on the altar of live demonstrations i
got this email hi how are you i thought
yeah i'm fine jacob how are you
sam newman can't make it to nbc oslo
we're looking for a replacement
would you be willing to help
uh
so i think i'm the right booking
it could be that it's one of the others
on my t-shirt
i just sent him that straight back of
course
[Laughter]
sorry jacob
okay so what am i going to be talking
about today so
ndc it's renowned as being a
practitioner's conference right it's
renowned as being very hands-on it's all
about code and you know i'm still a
developer so i still love that but i
think sometimes it's interesting and
useful to chunk up a bit to think a
little bit about some of the higher
level abstractions around how code gets
put together
how teams work how organizations are
designed how the places in which we work
how how they work and why they work the
way they do
and really that's been my sort of
journey over the last
i don't know what is it seven years
since we published the work on
microservice martin farrell myself
um so this talk is really about that
it's about my journey
around microservices and what's happened
since so martin and i said we cannot say
there's a formal definition of the
microservices architectural style
instead we went on to list a set of
characteristics
and for those of you who are in um the
you know the great talk about cupid by
daniel tears north um on i want to say
monday i wasn't unfortunately because i
was on the same time
but dan was talking about the idea of
properties or characteristics as opposed
to principles because characteristics
are inclusive properties are inclusive
as opposed to you know fawn against with
principles
and we deliberately called out
characteristics things that we were
doing that we were seeing
our teams in thoughtworks which is where
i work
and other big organizations netflix you
know the kind of guardian newspaper
lots of investment banks
lots of folks around the world the
things that they were doing at scale
that made them successful we tried to
pull them all together into one place
you can think of it as a sort of meta
study really
it's taking all the things that people
were doing that were working back in
2012 2013
uh and putting them together and these
were the characteristics
componentization by services organized
around business capabilities blah blah
blah
i'm not really good talking about these
in much detail although i'm going to be
talking about what i think are the
underlying principles
that make these work or why
these have become characteristics
associated with with
distributed systems microservices
architecture which is pretty much the
predominant uh architectural style out
there at the moment for better or worse
i'm sorry right
it goes to martinville's website
everyone thinks it's awesome that's just
how this stuff works
over the last few years i've been
thinking about
are there any underlying
properties any underlying
characteristics this if you look at a
few of these componentization but
organized around business capabilities
products not projects decentralized
governance there's decentralized data
management as well
this idea of decentralization of pushing
decision making down to the people who
know the most
and having them make decisions at the
point they know the most not the point
they know the least
um and you know decentralizing software
itself decentralizing it into
smaller systems that use the fluidity
principle if you saw my talk on monday
morning about lego don juanitson talks
about the fluidity principle as a core
principle for uh for decoupling systems
building things in separate bits in
parallel so you can plug them together
later on
so these small things that are
communicating via a uniform interface
generally
um and decentralizing you know
decentralizing them so they're cohesive
and decoupled from one another these
seem to be sort of
underlying characteristics around
microservices
i promised that i'd talk about team
topology software architecture and
complexity science in this talk so the
first bit is about team topologies
now who in the room has read
the great book team topologies manual
price matt skelton
not that many of you actually
which is good because it means the rest
of you get to discover it for yourself
so this is a book about well really it's
another meta study if you like well i
think it is
where the two authors have gathered a
whole bunch of information from how you
know
we we know that
a whole bunch of information from teams
that are building software successfully
and put them together into one place and
describe the common language a
ubiquitous language in ddd terms that we
can all use to talk about team
structures
successful team structures
and what do those team structures look
like well they tend to be organized
around something called flow
the idea of the flow of stuff
the flow of information the flow of
requirements the flow of value from as
my old nmd used to say from soup to nuts
from concept to cash which dan says
from concept to the customer saying
thank you
so that's what this book is about it's
about organizing our teams so that
requirements flow so that
software flows that commits flow
easily through from idea through into
production where they can make money
before i get into the types of team they
talk about i'd like to sort of tell you
a little story about this
symposium i was at it's an academic
thing i was at um
in the caribbean it's a terrible life
going to these things i tell you
so i was on anguilla at this little
little workshop
and there was some from amazon there
from aws in particular and they said the
bigger we get
the easier it becomes to get bigger
the more people we add in aws the more
teams we bring on board
the easier it is to bring more teams on
the easier it is
to build more products
the bigger we get
the easier
it becomes to get bigger and i was kind
of a little taken aback by that right i
mean that seems to
not be how stuff works in my experience
who works in a company where as you
bring more people in it's easier to
onboard than new people
there's normally one there you go one do
you work for aws
no okay right who do you work for
oh okay fine yeah i'm not sure
as i said there's always one
thank you maybe we could talk afterwards
you know the majority of us work in
organizations which follow the the
general rule as you add more people
things slow down as you add more people
the overhead increases communication
overhead increases
things get slower and slower and slower
that is the predominant my predominant
experience
and i suggest probably the predominant
experience of people in the room
this brings me to this concept of flow
the goal of successful organizational
design in my opinion is to optimize the
flow of value all else is subordinate to
that
we should be looking to design
information organizations and teams and
therefore software architectures
where the flow of information the flow
of value
is
is the thing that we're optimizing for
it's the forcing function
if you like
so what is it about aws
what is it about amazon they have this
organizational design which means that
it's easy for them to add new teams
because that implies the flow of value
is faster with aws the flow of value is
faster with those teams
than with bigger organizations where
it's harder
daniel tears northey has a different way
of looking at this i like this though
we should be looking as a team to safely
and sustainably reduce the leads time to
thank you i like that idea
but what is values i'll go back there's
someone taking a photo
pleasure
what is value so you know
what do we think of as value in our
organizations on our teams when we're
building software when we're writing
code
well i would say value is just stuff
right because you know what we do which
is about bits it's about knowledge it's
about information flow
that generates value we take stuff
that's sort of a raw material someone's
idea a feature request a business
requirements document
still exist
a business requirements document and we
turn it through success of like through
a sausage maker if you like successively
adding more information to these things
until at the end we get something
concrete which we can deploy into
production which is we hope valuable
it's stuff
but
physical
and informational knowledge stuff
are essentially the same
the systems that we work in
you know doing knowledge work
are the same as a supply chain
optimization problem for a supermarket
you know that's the flow of stuff from
an orange been picked on a tree in
seville through into tesco's and through
therefore onto your table or a
manufacturing process where you get raw
materials and you turn it via a set of
machines into progressively more
complicated widgets there's a flow of
value until you get something that's
accrued enough value that it's valuable
to be sold
but they're the same thing essentially
just one's physical ones informational
digital
they're the same thing the flow of value
it's basically taking raw materials
passing it through a network of machines
if you like or flowing through a system
of work and turning it into a thing
now i'll give you an example from
a retailer i was working out in northern
spain with no names but you might be
able to work at that
they could go from a designer like
clothes designer
putting their pencil down
all right on the you know they've done
their knife designs sketch it all out
they put their pencil down 15 days later
that design is in shops around the world
right you go from pencil down design
an idea through into a physical product
15 days later all across the world
they're probably the most highly
optimized supply chain in the world
but then when you look at things like
the set of dora reports or the book
accelerate
that's really what that's talking about
when we're thinking about things like
you know like lead times they talk about
lead times mean time to value need time
to value
we're talking about how quickly we can
go from code through into production
and elite high performing teams do that
on demand 15 however many times a day
low performing teams not so much
but that's what we're thinking about in
terms of value and flow and that's what
teams apologies talks about in terms of
optimizing team structures and coming up
with a ubiquitous language to help us
all optimize our team structures for
flow
this is an example of how you don't
optimize for flow
this is an example of a value stream map
a real one
from a client i was at a while ago and
what this shows is
right over this end
still this end if you're over there
looking at that one this end
that's where requirements are captured
this bit here is where they're deployed
there's a tiny little blue poster up
there i think it might have a laser
maybe not
there's a tiny little blue poster
in there
that's writing code that is
my favorite bit of this is this bit in
the middle where you've got these
circular things
that's two enterprise data architects on
different teams who've each got a
canonical data model and they just go
around in circle updating each other's
economical data model
one feels that they don't understand
what canonical might might mean
doesn't mean what they think it means
clearly but this is an example of a very
old organization that over time have
accrued lots and lots of process steps
in order to deliver value something
happened at one point maybe it was black
friday and the website went down they
couldn't sell anything so let's do a six
week period of integration of sorry you
know regression testing
you get these long long value streams
especially in bigger older organizations
the rest of this talk is about why that
is
so back to teams apologies teams
apologies describes four different types
of team
talks about this idea of a streamlined
team
this is a team we talk in microservices
land about product teams right product
teams organized around value streams
delivering value to a customer you
should have line of sight to a customer
that was one of jeff bezos's lines in
his famous memo each team should have a
line of sight
to the customer so streamline teams you
can think of this maybe a retail website
you might have one value stream or
streamline team delivering search one
delivering baskets say one doing a
catalog page
and so on
you then have enabling teams
complicated subsystem teams and platform
teams
the idea behind these other teams is
that they make the stream align teams go
faster
why do we want a platform
why is aws useful
because it makes us
better faster at delivering value that's
why we have platform engineering teams
we hope they can build tools in order to
make the other teams go faster or help
the other teams go faster and then
enabling teams this is to manage scarce
resources
we all know there aren't enough security
engineers to go around
there aren't enough really
super good infrastructure folks not
enough really good user researchers so
you create enabling teams you can act as
consultants
to the other teams helping them go
faster providing limited
skills so you have these four
fundamental topologies talked about in
the book
and it enables us to have a conversation
about how we design our teams around our
software
and i'm going to go back to conway's law
here
this is an assumption that everyone
knows
about conway's law comey's law states
that
the way your teams are structured
dictates how your architecture is going
to look
so when i'm talking about teams i'm
talking synonymously with software
architecture here
so how we organize our teams is the same
as how we organize
our sets of domains our micro services
in business capabilities and so on
which brings me on to the next topic
software architecture and complexity
because you know
designing teams is all very well
designed in organizations very well but
where software engineers software
architects probably some of us
although i would describe myself as a
coding architect i think architecture is
an activity that gets done as opposed to
a role
um you can have you can have an
architect role and not do any
architecture i would argue
but architecture and complexity
back to what
this guy there was a guy from amazon
said aws
the bigger we get the easier it gets to
get bigger
the more people we add the easier it is
to add more people the more products we
build the easier it is to build more
products
in fact he went as far as to say our
only limit on the number of products we
could be building
is the number of people we can hire
well that's how quickly we can go at aws
and if you think about it what they've
built is this sort of foundational
platform so what they're able to do is
plonk new teams on
you know those teams are able to take
advantage of prior art
they're they don't really they're
separated from one another they're just
able to plonk these teams on
but as i said this sort of flies in the
face
of what we usually think of when we
think about
certainly software projects you know
this is the
the classic quote adding manpower to a
software project makes it later this is
receive wisdom
and this was done on the basis of a good
piece of research
which showed that as you add more people
into a project that becomes a there
becomes a tipping point where the
information the amount of
the amount of chatting we have to do the
amount of coordination we have to
perform between ourselves
overtakes the benefits of the
productivity of the new person all the
new people
so there's a natural limit to the size
in fact microservices was part in partly
a way of sort of if you like
sidestepping this problem
getting around it by saying well if we
break stuff up into little bits then we
can have more people working on the
little bits right that's the that's the
idea
sort of sidestepping around it
um my favorite sidestepping of a maths
thing story was from uh a google talk i
was at i can't remember which databases
they're like massively global
consistent blah blah blah database which
has got all the they bought all the
atomic clocks to make it run right
and at the end of the talk the google
guy said um yes i know we're consistent
and available
in the event of a of a partition that
should be impossible right according to
cap theorem you can only have two out of
those three he said the thing is we're
not really
it's just that our networks are so good
at google we never have network
partitions
which i thought was quite entertaining
he's like we're going to sidestep that
by pretending that our networks are
perfect and maybe they are at google
anyway
back to aws
i sort of went home and i ran the
numbers as far as i could
i had a look at the
amount of money they're making
per employee essentially at amazon
i plotted it on a graph based on
publicly available data at the time
there's not much of it
so the data science folk in the room you
can help me with fruit if you like but i
used what i had
studio graph coming up
this is log log so what this shows is as
amazon are doubling in size
in terms of the number of employees
they're making more than double
the revenue that exponent 1.15 up there
forget the rest of it but the 1.15 that
means they're making 15 more revenue
than they should if you like they're
more than doubling the amount of revenue
they're making 1.15
instead of one if they were growing
exponentially if revenue growth was
exponential with employee count they
would double employees double
revenue
but they're not they're in advance of
that right they're doing better than
they should
i thought that's interesting and
intriguing
why is that is it something to do with
the way
they're structured the way their
software is architected the way their
teams work
because clearly
this guy was saying
we can go as fast as possible
or
we can go as fast as
we can bring on new team members
so i went back again and thought about
what happened 10 years ago when they
were 15 years 20 years ago probably even
now when they moved from monoliths
big monolithic architectures based
around databases and databases to
database communication lots of big
oracle instances and so on through to
where they are today which is
somewhat service oriented in terms of
amazon.com and then you know with aws
these small teams building small
products disconnected from one another
and all that way back in 2004 one of the
things that jeff bezos communicated was
that from this point on we must
communicate all teams must communicate
via interfaces there's there's to be no
fertiling with each other's
databases anymore
cf joke about c
c plus plus and
private no
talking to each other's databases
everything must be through an api
everything must be through an interface
those interfaces must be externalizable
what does that mean they must be
hardened we must be able to sell them we
must be able to use these as an
additional revenue stream if necessary
and we're actually going to manage
profit and loss within our own teams
that's what these interfaces and these
teams based around these should be
doing
and then this famous idea around two
pizza teams right everyone's come across
the famous amazon two pizza team
i've called that dunbar's number here
cause that makes more sense i'll talk
about that in a moment
what all these things are these three
characteristics
thou shalt do these things
are forcing functions to enable flow
forcing functions to enable the flow of
work within amazon.com and within aws
value as quickly through into production
as possible
via a set of architectural constraints
if you like on the software and the
teams
so what we're doing is we're limiting
interaction to nearby teams right it's a
great example
at the same simplest when i was as there
was someone from netflix and they said
well what we do is we we sit people who
need to talk to one another close to one
another this is in the before times
now everyone's a zoom call away right
teams call away if you're unlucky
but we limit interaction to people who
are close to us
people i don't need to talk to they can
sit over there doesn't really matter i
don't need to speak to the cassandra
admins on a day-to-day basis if i'm
working on you know the samsung ux code
right but i might need to talk to the
platform team or the platform api team
because you know they're the people i
need to actually make get to make
changes for me and things so i'll sit
i'll sit quite close to them that way
not only can we have the
normal formal conversations but we might
be able to have the sort of
serendipitous conversations about work
there's a great piece of work by a guy
called thomas allen years and years ago
now and you wrote a phd thesis on it it
was a study on research and development
organizations or departments
and he looked at how distant you needed
to be from other engineers before
you stopped talking to them after about
six seven meters the chances of you
accidentally having
like a work conversation that was
meaningful is zero pretty much across
the board
after six seven meters and that's that
includes a staircase
you're not going to have these
serendipitous conversations with people
right so sit people who need to talk to
each other close to each other
and separate the others might sound
obvious
but these are forcing functions for flow
isolate our teams
use the fluidity principle so we can
break these teams up into smaller units
which can be linked together but they're
isolated from one another
via these interfaces these
externalizable interfaces
and then scale by this well-known factor
called dunbar's number and if you
haven't come across dunbar's number it's
normally people talk about the dunbar's
number of about 200 150 the number of
people or connections you hold the
number of number of colleagues that you
could reasonably be expected to know the
kids names of or whether they like golf
or whether they like swimming or cycling
or whatever any more than that you start
to lose
they're just people
it just becomes faces in a crowd if you
like
and thorwicks we'll come to this later
with thor which we used to scale via
dunbar's number it's slightly different
now but whenever we got an office size
over about 200
spin up a new office
keeps the culture of the office
and i'm nice and tight
so you scale by dunbar's number
a number of these dumbbells numbers
you limit interaction
and isolate teams forcing functions for
flow
fine james you've just told me stuff i
already know but this i think is the
interesting bit because there's maths
that shows why this works
so strap in calculus coming up no not
really it's not
on a wednesday morning there's no
calculus there's one more graph
maybe three more graphs
so what are complex adaptive systems so
they the the idea of causes complex
adaptive system or complexity science
came out from this place called the
santa fe institute
in new mexico
it's no coincidence in it's in new
mexico it's really close to the the los
alamos national laboratory which is also
there in new mexico it's where the
manhattan project was run
it's where a lot of very famous very
bright
physicists worth for many a year my
favorite story about los alamos was that
on a on a friday night their poker game
just needs to have a random poker game
it would have 13 then current nobel
prize winners playing poker
and that didn't include murray gale man
who started the santa fe institute who
went on to win one or richard feynman
who also were playing poker that's
pretty impressive set of brains there
but a bunch of these folk went off and
they got interested in things like chaos
theory they they got interested in how
these really small interactions can
cause well chaos the butterfly effect
you know things like monte carlo
simulation came from los alamos
and murray gale man in particular was
fascinated by the idea of how you get
complexity from simplicity
how you go from something as simple as a
quark
which he helped discover two something
as complex as a jaguar and he wrote a
book called quark on the jaguar about
this
how do you go from these indivisible
units up to something that thinks and
breathes and lives
has its own children
and that's what this study of complexity
science is all about
so here's a couple of questions there
might be more than three graphs
there's an interesting fact about mice
and elephants and humans
did you know that our blood pressures
are all the same
we have the same blood pressure as a
blue whale
within bars
or a mouse
we all share the same blood pressure is
invariant across mammal's size
another thing that's invariant across
mammal size
is heartbeats per lifetime
you've got a couple of billion doesn't
matter if you're marriage you're an
elephant you're a human there are some
invariants across all mammals everywhere
but if you have that kind of thing going
on
have these invariants
you probably need some variants too
right and what varies with mammals is
heart rate
one thing
mice's heart beats a lot lot faster than
ours
elephant's heart beats really really
really slowly blue whales even slower
in fact what you find if you plot the
metabolic rate
of mammals with size
is a straight line on a graph
this is from the book well that's
actually from a paper it's summarized in
the book scale i'll reference that at
the end
but jeffrey west and james brown
they found that as you double the size
of a mammal
metabolic rate doesn't double
it decreases that's the variant
actually the double the size of a thing
you don't have to eat twice as much you
don't take on twice as many calories
things slow down the body slows down
elephants don't get cancer
you know that's kind of fascinating
because their cells divide
so so few so many fewer times than ours
do
they don't get the opportunity to get
the genetic kind of problems you know
building up
the um defects building up and then
causing cancer
they experience the world very very
slowly
we look like we're running around like
crazy fools right
like mice look to us
metabolic rate in mammals follows a
scaling law with an exponent of three
over four
as a mammal doubles in size
it only needs 75 of the calories
there are other examples of complex
adaptive systems mammals are one
organizations are another complex
adaptive system
so what about a news agent a mom and pop
stall and a big supermarket
well the interesting thing with these
two
is if you plot revenue by employee count
you get another straight line
this is from the nasdaq
and what you find again is as you double
the size of a company
you don't double the amount of revenue
you get
in fact revenue scales number of
employees blah with an exponent of 0.85
as you double the size of a company you
only get about 85
of the revenue
that you might expect you might expect
to get double
but you don't you get 85 percent
another example of a complex adaptive
system is a city or town
right
as you go from one size city and double
it to another size so you go from a
village to a town town to a
bigger town because i don't know what
the variations in these things are
bigger towns or a city city to a bigger
city i don't know
what you find is you spend less on
infrastructure that you might than you
might expect
as you double the size of a city you
only have to spend 85 volts i think it's
yeah 85 percent
of the money you would expect you only
need 85 percent of the petrol stations
85 percent of the roads 85 percent of
the uh of the sewage pipes 85
of the light bulbs
in street lights
as you double in size
so what we have here is a set of scaling
rules that are invariable that that are
similar across lots of different things
and the thing they have in common is
that they are complex adaptive systems
jeffrey west in the book scale he says
that quantities that do not change when
other parameters of the system change
they play a special role in science and
in fact there's a name for the
phenomenon i just showed you economists
call this
economies of scale
this is
what our
when the economies of scale need to get
bigger we'll get economies of scale
and they're right
you do
for certain things
so linear scaling or exponential growth
if you like plotted like this
as one one quantity doubles the other
quantity also doubles
then you have this idea of economies of
scale sub-linear scaling
whereas you double one number
the other number increases by less than
you'd expect or less than double
so infrastructure in cities
revenue for organizations metabolic rate
in mammals all follow this scaling rule
they all scale sub linearly
why isn't that well
i'm not going to tell you have to go and
find out yourself thanks very much i'll
be off there
that i will get on to that in a second
because it's related to this fact that
they're all complex adaptive systems
what are complex adaptive systems
so they have these four characteristics
they display self-similarity
so essentially a complex adaptive system
is anything that can be built from
self-similar parts
right ourselves are the same as an
elephant's cells when you get right down
to it
at times a house in one
village is the same as a house in
another village or in a city as you
scale
self-similar parts
they're self-organizing
essentially there's no central conductor
that tells the jaguar to build itself
the jaguars sort of turns into a jaguar
via self-organization mediated by dna
they display complexity so the whole is
greater than the sum of the parts
you know if you sort of atomize the
jaguar and then threw all the atoms
together again
probably wouldn't get a jaguar you get a
bunch of atoms right
the hole is greater than the sum of the
parts and they display emergent behavior
so the behavior of the whole system
can't be predicted from the behavior of
the parts of the system
and of course this is related if you've
come across dave snowden's work around
kinevin this is related to the complex
part of the kinevin model
so all these different complex adaptive
systems
display these characteristics and the
fascinating thing about the maths now
there's math that shows that these four
characteristics can be built from three
simple
mathematical principles and there is a
proof
which i won't go into
but those three simple principles are
quite interesting i think
so the first one is this concept of
space filling fractal networks all the
name all the words mean something very
specific because maths point being you
have these networks
anything that has a network
that looks a bit like this that is space
filling fractal network right that's one
of the properties of a complex adaptive
system
in us it's our circulatory systems
it's our nervous systems
information flowing blood flowing
through those hierarchies through the
networks that we have inside us
the same as an elephant in an
organization it's the network cables
it's
people talking to one another it's email
chains right the hierarchies of
information flow
these networks that we have
in cities it's
the road networks it's the water pipes
that come in and
there's a word for it split into many
small parts before they get into uh your
house say
you then have this idea of invariant
terminating units which is what i'm
desperately trying to get our staffing
people like folk in thoughtworks
to start calling us consultants
because i think this is way better than
they normally call as meat bags
i think this is like a step up from
meatbacks right
that's in there in terminating units
right people in organizations and
and
like houses in cities and in mammals in
living creatures it sells
essentially you know cells that you get
these
uh these networks feeding if you like
and then finally some mechanism for
optimization
feedback
i gave up smoking two and a half years
ago
oh it's time for a nicotine replacement
thing sorry about that
it was the best and the worst time to
give up smoking right in the middle of a
pandemic right it's like
yay my lungs boo i really want a
cigarette but anyway moving on
optimization
optimization you know for for for
mammals that's optimization that's
mediated over geological time by
evolution
for the other two examples that's a
market forces essentially whether a city
grows or not or whether a company gets
bigger or not
based on feedback from the market
forces and these simple properties three
simple properties they can explain all
the lines i showed you they can explain
why you get this complexity emerging
from simplicity
at the end of this section i'm just
going to sum up and say you know these
these causes are everywhere they can be
described by these three principles
network effects
optimization and self
like invariant terminating units
when you have hierarchical networks
like our circulatory system or like the
information flow in hierarchical
companies or like the branching and
splitting of hierarchies of water pipes
you will always follow
this power law with an exponent of less
than one
you can't do better than that can't do
better than as you double in size
getting as much out doubling them out
that you get out generally what you'll
do is you double in size you get less
out than you think which is good if it's
going to cost you money
as you double the size of a company you
only have to spend 85 percent of money
on network cables
but you only get 85 percent of the
revenue
fundamentally this self-similar thing is
kind of fun we are the same same as
animals like mice the etruscan shrew and
us is no different mathematically we're
both examples of complex adaptive
systems optimized by geological time by
evolution over geological time
so let's come on to this idea of
corporate metabolism because i talked
about mammals and how mammals you know
bigger the animal the slower they get
but there's also this thing with age
the bigger the the older the animal the
slower they get to
metabolism slows down with age
so why does revenue growth
slow a size increase why do we get this
straight line
why do metabolic rates slow size
increases
and it's fundamentally down to this
interesting these interesting networks
talks about networks talked about it
being one of the first principles the
first principle
the network of facts
cause metabolic rates to slow down they
cause the effect of not having to spend
as much on infrastructure over time
and there's a really interesting reason
for this and it's based on this idea of
back pressure and optimization
because systems optimize for the flow of
stuff
so for example if you go from a water
pipe giant water pipe feeding london
there's more than one i appreciate right
it splits and splits and splits and
splits and splits and splits until you
turn on your tap that's the invariant
terminating unit and the water isn't
going to flow right
same with us we've got a heart we've got
a big big pipe called called the aorta
and as it splits and splits and splits
and splits and splits and splits it gets
down to capillaries all right which is
feed that they're the the width that can
feed
cells essentially
if they didn't get down as small as
capillaries then our cells wouldn't get
any nutrients we wouldn't be able to
live
the funny thing is about that as well is
as you go from arteries where you can
take a pulse it's right you get a pump
action from the heart
the capillaries are so so narrow
that blood flows there's laminar flow
through them basically constant flow
there's no pumping mechanism through the
capillaries right because if it was
pumped there wouldn't be enough time for
the nutrients to skip over the boundary
cells wouldn't get any energy
and the difference between a mouse
and us and us in a blue whale
is simply the number of layers of artery
that we have
just counting the number of layers of
artery mathematically will give you our
metabolic rate we'll plots on that graph
that's weird
very weird people nodding it's very very
weird
i don't believe you james it's true
there's maths there's papers i've
referenced them at the end
in fact the smallest mammal which is
about the size of my thumbnail the
etruscan shrew it only has basically the
heart in one little artery then
capillaries
but it has to have some form of pumping
mechanism
to get blood around
blue whales
they have lots of layers
as you add more layers
things slow down
blue whales are slower than etruscans
through their metabolic rate because
they've got more depth of hierarchy
that's just maths
there's another funny thing as well
so in terms of optimization
every time one of the like an artery or
a water pipe splits what what what
an engineer would do with the water pipe
is make sure they split into
pipes with the same cross-sectional area
so the two that it splits into when you
add them together you get
the one above it
and the reason is if you didn't have
that the water would rebound off
the pipe boundary and it would put back
pressure up the system
and blow up the water pumping station
somewhere
same with us with evolution evolution is
optimized every time one of our arteries
splits it splits into two blood vessels
with the same total cross-sectional area
as it was before otherwise blood would
be rebounding off the
off that boundary
you get an impedance mismatch and
basically you put undue pressure on the
heart
you get a heart attack this is why
plaque
cholesterol is so bad because it narrows
the arteries it causes essentially the
heart to beat against itself
that's kind of
well fundamentally when you look at
complex adaptive systems that involve
hierarchical networks these circulatory
systems
what you have is these invariant
terminating units at the bottom cells
and then you have layers of hierarchy
and the depth of the hierarchy
corresponds to how much slope more
slowly things go
so bigger animals they're more efficient
if you like because you only need to eat
75 percent of the stuff but
because of this the way the circulatory
system has evolved over time driven by
feedback from evolution they go a lot
slower
bigger companies are more efficient
and they develop deeper and deeper
deeper and deeper hierarchies or tend to
as they age
i see i refer you to my uh value stream
map from earlier from an older
organization really deep
long value stream map really deep
hierarchy through which information is
flowing stuff value is flowing
they develop these deeper hierarchies
and both of these things they slow down
as they get older
so flow i'm going to come back to this
valley stream map because i think it's
interesting really value stream maps
when you when you look at them they're
just a view through
the hierarchy of an organization right
they're a view of how you get work from
one place
to the place it's supposed to be
delivering value
from requirements captured through into
production
they're very sliced if you like through
the corporate information hierarchy
that's a fun thing you can see in this
valley stream map these little arrows
are pointing to
hughes
hughes of jira tickets backlogs
requirements sitting there doing nothing
just hanging around waiting for someone
to pick them up and do something
right
now when we look at uh
how flow works
from an economic perspective in the
principles of product development flow
don monnison points out that cues create
all sorts of issues
the longer something sits in a queue a
work item then the more chance that
something's going to change and the
requirement becomes out of date say
the the deeper the queue the longer it
takes anything to get done
and so what we have with this idea of
corporate metabolism
is as companies grow as they scale as
they get bigger they add more layers
into their corporate hierarchy they add
more process stages to get stuff done
you add more process and more hierarchy
and
its maths
the more hierarchy you add in these
networks
the slower you will go
there's just maths
but we also deliberately block
our corporate arteries
we do stuff that personally
i find irritating i suspect some of
these examples you might do
so can we actually identify the signs of
aging in our organization and take
action potentially to speed things up to
get younger the elixir of life
can we do that so in the book accelerate
which is the summary of the state of
devops reports over a number of years
they identify four key metrics which are
the equivalent if you like of taking
your pulse your blood pressure your
temperature
leading indicators of corporate health
of corporate uh metabolism
but before i get to those here's a fun
fact who likes change request boards
wake up bueller
no architects review boards
who's got an architectural review board
they have to go to
yeah
so in accelerates they find that i'm
going to use this word precisely change
your quest boards architecture review
boards predict
low performance
i'm using that in the
precise statistical sense they predict
low performance
and if you think about flow if you think
about what i've been talking about it's
kind of obvious really why because what
we're doing is we're deliberately
blocking
it's like we're
we're stopping the blood supply to our
arm for a bit by applying a tourniquet
and then we're then releasing it
that's essentially what we're doing when
we're putting requests into a change
request board or an architectural review
board they predict low performance
but we can use the tools from accelerate
to predict well so sorry to
as leading indicators of organizational
health so mean time to recovery
cycle time they call out change failure
rate
number of deploys there's a new one
added which i think is availability i
can't remember
and we can use these to
test whether we're getting faster or
slower and work to improve them
again daniel turtle's north he's got
this lovely line we should be working to
sustainably and safely reduce the lead
time to thank you
and by optimizing around these 4k
metrics we can do that
so they're leading indicators of all
health is it like monitoring your blood
pressure it's the same because it's the
same network effect that's that's going
on
it's the same thing with flow
but you should remember that any
improvement you make are is always going
to be limited
by the depth of hierarchy
hierarchies imply hierarchies mean that
we can only get so fast
and we can get no faster
but we can work to reach the limit by
optimizing the 4k metrics
organizational mortality
so the churn
on
the half-life of an organization
enlisted or listed company
not anyone in particular so i said
half-life the half-life
of a listening company is 10 and a half
years every 10 and a half years there's
50 churn
on any
you know on the nasdaq on ftse or
whatever it is
companies die all the time they get
taken over
they they go bankrupt they go into
administration
etc etc and why is that
well it seems as if
over time organizations and there's less
data available on this because you know
there's more publicly available data on
um
on on cities and mammals
but it seems as if over time
organizations spend less on r d they
spend less on the thing that made them
vital if you like to begin with
which was the products they were
building for their customers to delight
them they concentrate less on doing that
they spend
they invest less of their metabolic
energy if you like
into
life into vitality into thriving and
more into cell repair
cost efficiencies
moving people around so we don't spend
as much money that kind of stuff
and it means that as these companies get
older they end up dying
you add more and more processes and
constraints until eventually everything
seizes up
and you've got nowhere to go
because the hierarchies are growing and
growing and growing adding more and more
processes and constraints
spending less on r d
until eventually like mammals
they cark it
so hierarchical organizations they gain
economies of scale for infrastructure
they achieve sub-linear growth in
revenue economies of scale for revenue
and they reduce their metabolic rate
over time
until they eventually
die thank you very much i'm james lewis
uh hope i haven't depressed you all too
much
i'm joking
because there's a way out everyone don't
worry but thank you for the applause
good
i should do that joke more often
you're awake or at least there's
probably someone at the back
well maybe all of you did
there's a way out right there's actually
a different way amazon are doing it aws
is doing it other companies have found a
way around this trap
and that's because there's another
straight line you can plot on this which
economists call returns to scale as you
double uh one number you get more than
double out
as opposed to less than double
cities do both cities have economies of
scale for infrastructure
and they have returns to scale
for socioeconomic factors so innovation
wages the number of professionals the
number of camera shops all sorts of
stuff
you get more than double
these things when you double the size of
a city
and you have less than double of road
lengthy infrastructure stuff
the infrastructure stuff that is based
on hierarchy
right the hierarchical networks
incidentally if you thought that people
walk faster in london than elsewhere
they do
mit did some research
as you double the size of a place people
walk faster it's actually a thing
they analyze mobile phone data
and that's the number they came up with
obviously up to the limit of needing
exoskeleton legs but
and the reason is because there's a
different type of network acting with
socioeconomic effects there's something
called a small world fractal network
same mathematical properties if you like
it's a fractal space filling network but
it operates it's not hierarchical
it's like your twitter friends it's like
facebook it's like a social network it's
like you're
it's it's like your connections with
your friends and family
and social networks drive super linear
growth i mentioned dunbar's number there
are more than one dumbass number
excuse me they scale from
five all the way up to 500. five is your
nuclear family
it's all good for me because i've got
four kids and my wife so i must love
either one of the kids less or my wife
less
but then you get 15 your close friends
your nuclear family if you like and
you're very close family then up to 50
which is probably your cousins and
things 150 or acquaintances 500 the
people you know that they like golf
and returns to scale are driven by
these types of networks social networks
hierarchies drive economies of scale
social networks drive returns to scale
and the reason is because small networks
you can grow stuff on the side you don't
need to in you know because you've got
to go back to comp so my data structures
and algorithms course inserting a node
into a linked list or into a graph or
whatever how you want to be doing that's
probably an interview question i've
failed at one of your companies
you don't need to do that right with
hierarchies you need to add depth
with smaller networks you just plug bits
in on the side you add suburbs where i
live in stevenage it's constantly having
these little suburbs little states added
on the side
without disrupting the rest of it
and that's why small world networks
drive returns to scale because they're
independent they're decoupled they're
isolated from one another
so as cities grow
they gain economies of scale for
infrastructure but returns to scale for
the other stuff it's not all good crime
more than doubles
disease more than doubles but so does
wages innovation and so on they also
rarely die
you can actually measure the crinkliness
of a city the boundary
the fractal dimension of a city tells
you how healthy it is and as detroit
sort of became ailing
over the last couple of decades and then
sort of sort of sparked back to life a
bit the fractal dimension has increased
of detroit actually measure that i think
you probably do the same with software
architectures i've not tried
fundamentally you get 115 of the stuff
for 85 percent of the cost this is why
cities work so well this is why they
tend to grow
they're more efficient and you get more
stuff for less money
who else does this right well
thoughtworks i mentioned we scale by
dunbar's number this country we've got
manchester london newcastle not just one
big head office india we've got
10 offices i don't know
china however many right we don't scale
by
having a giant office we scale by trying
to create smaller communities smaller
bits of smaller cultures that are
decoupled
spotify you can argue the spotify model
is exactly an attempt to document a
small how to grow a company using small
world networks using the squads loosely
coupled from one another with just
enough hierarchy to enable cross-team
cross-organization
communication
valve the computer games publisher
they even put their when they leaked
leaked
their team you know their handbook for
new joiners they have this in it this
was in plain sight
10 years ago they said we are scaling
via small world network growth this is
what we do
because it's more effective
and then finally back to amazon and aws
they're growing in advance of
exponential
they're growing with an exponent 1.15 in
this graph they get more revenue out
than they should as i said at the start
as they get bigger it gets easier to get
bigger it's the same number as i was
showing you for smaller limit growth in
other situations
so for amazon right
as most companies get bigger it gets
harder to get bigger and the reasons are
mathematical the reasons are to do with
hierarchy with age was slowing down with
metabolism the same reason that we slow
down as we get older the same reason
that we're slower than a mouse and an
elephant
is slower than us
but as amazon gets bigger
it's easier for them to get bigger
i'll refer you back to team topologies
talked about team topology software
architecture and flow
i'm using team structure organizational
structure these network designs
synonymously essentially
as we put our teams together we're
building loosely coupled components
around these streamlined teams right
decoupled with enabling teams enabling
those teams to go faster
when you're building these teams around
social networks
you're not limited by the structures
imposed by hierarchy
you're limited only by the team that you
have yourself that are isolated from
others and you can add more and more and
more
so in summary
it's been well 2014
martin farrow and myself published
the paper on microservices and you know
i've been
writing code yes but i've also been
thinking about
why those things seem to work why has it
become so successful as a
as an architectural style what is now
data mesh
exploding
data mesh is an expression i think of
microservices architecture it's an
expression of what i'm talking about as
well it's an evolution of microservices
and it's based around this idea of
decentralization decoupling organized
around stable concerns
business capabilities we call that
organizers around your business domains
not technological concerns
now team topologies is a ubiquitous
language we can use amongst ourselves to
talk about how to structure ourselves to
optimize for flow for flow of
information through small world networks
so i'll finally leave you with this
social networks implies super
exponential growth
hierarchies they slow things down it's
just maths
we can apply inversion of control for
teams
and we can use forcing functions for
flow
this is the research i've summarized
this is not my own work
this is a report back on what i've
learned over the last decade or so so
team topologies accelerate scale quark
and jaguar and flow and on that note i
think i'll say thank you very much this
really is the end
thank
and luckily there's no time for
questions hahaha i'll be out there
though cheers
you